is the relation given by the set of
ordered pairs shown below a function so
before we even attempt to do this
problem right here let's just remind
ourselves what a relation is and what
type of relations can be functions so in
a relation you have a set of numbers
that you can kind of view as the input
into the relation we call that the
domain you could view them as the set of
numbers over which that relation is
defined and then you have a set of
numbers that can be you can view it as
the output of the relation or what the
numbers that can be associated with
anything in domain and we call that the
range and it's a fairly straightforward
idea so for example let's say that the
number 1 is in the domain and that we
associate the number one with the number
two in the range so in this type of
notation you would say that the relation
has 1 comma 2 1 comma 2 in its in its
set of ordered pairs these are two ways
of saying the same thing now the
relation can also say hey maybe if I
have to maybe that is associated with 2
as well so 2 is also associated with the
number 2 and so notice I'm just building
a bunch of associations I visually drawn
them over here here I'm just doing them
as ordered pairs we could say that we
have the number 3 3 is in our domain our
relation is defined for number 3 and 3
is associated with I want to say
negative negative 7 so this is 3 and
negative 7 now this type of relation
right over here where if you give me any
member of the domain and I'm able to
tell you exactly which member of the
range is associated with it this is also
referred to as a function and in the net
in a few seconds I'll show you what a
relation that is not a function because
over here you pick any member of the
domain and the function really is just a
relation it's really just an association
sometimes called a mapping between
members of the domain and particular
members of the range so you give me any
member of the domain I'll tell you
exactly which member of the range it
maps to you give me one I say hey
definitely maps to two you give me
- definitely Maps tattoo as well you
give me three it's definitely associated
with negative seven as well so this
relation is both a it's obviously a
relation but it is also a function now
to show you a relation that is not a
function imagine something like this so
once again I'll draw a domain over here
and I do this big fuzzy cloud looking
thing to show you that I'm not showing
you all of the things in the domain I'm
just picking specific examples and let's
say that this big fuzzy cloud looking
thing is the range and let's say in this
relation and I'll build it the same way
that we built it over here let's say in
this relation one is associated with two
so let's build the set of ordered pairs
so one is associated with two let's say
that two is associated with let's say
that two is associated with negative
three so you'd have two negative three
over there and let's say on top of that
we also associate we also associate one
with the number four
so we also create an association with
one with the number four so we have the
ordered pair 1 comma 4 now this is a
relationship we have it's defined for
certain if this was the whole
relationship then the entire domain is
just the numbers 1 2 actually just the
numbers 1 & 2 it's definitely a relation
but this is no longer function and the
reason why it's no longer a function is
if you tell me okay I'm giving you 1 in
the domain what member of the range is 1
associated with it over here you say
well I don't know is 1 associated with 2
or is it associated with 4 it could be
either one so you don't have a clear
association if I give you 1 here you're
like I don't know do I hand you a 2 or 4
that's not what a function does a
function says if you give me 1 I know
I'm giving you a 2 you give me 2 I know
I'm giving you 2 now that on the way
let's actually try to tackle the problem
right over here so let's think about its
domain and let's think about its range
so the domain here the possible the
possible you could view them as X values
or inputs into this thing that could be
a function that's definitely a relation
you could have a negative 3 you could
have a negative 2 you could have a 0 you
could have a well we already listed a
negative 2 so that's right over there
or you could have a positive three or
you could have a positive three those
are the possible values that this
relation is defined for that you could
input into this relation and figure out
what it outputs now the range here these
are the possible outputs or the numbers
that are associated with the numbers in
the domain the range includes two four
five two four five six six and eight two
four five six and eight I could have
drawn this with a big you know a cloud
like this and I could have done this
with a cloud like this but here we're
showing the exact numbers in the domain
and the range and I'll now let's draw
the actual associations so negative
three is associated with two or it's a
map to two so negative three maps to two
based on this ordered pair right over
there then we have negative 2 is
associated with 4 so negative 2 is
associated with 4 based on this ordered
pair right over there show you that
first ordered pair let me that first
ordered pair I should I don't want to
get the get you confused it should just
be this ordered pair right over here
negative 3 is associated with 2 then we
have negative 2 we do that in a
different color we have negative 2 is
associated with 4 negative 2 is
associated with 4 we have 0 is
associated with 5 zero is associated 5
more sometimes people say it's mapped to
5 we have negative 2 is mapped to 6 now
this is interesting negative 2 is
already mapped to something and it's now
this this ordered pair saying it's also
mapped it's also mapped to 6 and then
finally finally I'll do this in a color
that I haven't used yet although I've
used almost all of them we have 3 is
mapped to 8 3 is mapped to 8 so the
question here is this a function and for
it to be a function for any member of
the domain you have to know what it's
going to map to it can only map to one
member of the range so negative 3 if you
put if you put negative 3 as the input
into the function you know it's going to
output 2 if you put negative 2 into the
input of the function all of a sudden
you get confused do I output 4 or do I
output 6 so you don't know if your
output 4 or
output six and because there's this
confusion this is not a function you
have you have a member of the domain
that maps to multiple members of the
range so this right over here is not a
function not a function